thank thank thank thank than cheers hey
cheers welcome everyone good swallowing
noises start the podcast off with just
drinking in your face welcome back to
the Jenna and Julian podcast yeah hi
five we are back with another episode of
talking about whatever we want however
we want this episode of the Jenna and
Julian uh podcast is brought to you by
boss dogs we love boss dogs boss dogs is
an awesome little company out of
Rochester yeah Hometown represent that's
right uh they make awesome apparel but
it's not just apparel it's specific to
your dog so if you want your dog to look
like this yeah they made Peach marbles
Kermit like we died laughing when they
sent them to us you literally need to
send them a picture of your dog and they
will create apparel of a of a graphic
design of that picture and they do a
great job we have shirts they send those
hoodies these hats uh boss dogs Co .c
that's boss doco.com you get 10% off at
checkout if you enter the code Jenna
Julian yeah we got our hats on we got
our mugs yeah we're all decked out we
are our our P Kermit and marble shirts
are in the wash yeah they're all dirty
incidentally cuz we wear them cuz we
wear them everywhere um so of course my
chair sounds like just over here Mar
needs to be in here today cuz he's
having a noisy day yeah we just decided
we bring him in so Hees having a noisy
day anyway thanks boss dogs for
supporting the podcast thank you boss
dogs and you guys are awesome they are
awesome and yay Rochester that's true
isn't that funny it very funny yeah uh
today we wanted to follow up on a
podcast we had sort of started a while
ago we preemptively spoke about the
Apple watch before anyone had it before
it was out at all and we talked about
what we thought and what what we thought
it was going to be like what we get it
and now we have them people have been
requesting that we them yeah and we've
had them for what two months now and uh
yeah we've had a lot of requests to talk
about what we think of the Apple watch
after having owned it for some time now
so that's what we're going to do we're
going to do our thoughts and our our
opinions of the Apple watch we wrote
like an outline of what we want to talk
about because yeah so uh [__] I
spilled my water on my phone and now it
like won't good humaning yeah we're
going to do our we're going to go over
our first impressions that we had when
we first got the watch our favorite apps
uh apps that we wish that they had for
the Apple watch our gripes with the
Apple watch future generation what we
think the next generation of the Apple
watch and the next uh software update
should include for the Apple watch and
then overall is it worth it yeah is that
everything yes okay so we have a couple
notes written down and we're each going
to go over the categories uh and say our
piece about what we think why don't you
start with uh with your first
impressions so just to clarify we both
have the Apple watch sport she's got the
38 mm I've got the 42 mm and we both
have space gray which is kind of like a
steel black it's really cool color I'm
happy with the color not get the silver
we didn't get the silver the silver is
the stainless steel that would have been
$100 more yeah right um was it $100 more
mhm oh I didn't the Apple watch Regular
yeah really cuz I felt like the space
the space gray was special so it was
like it looks it looks like it should be
yeah whatever okay so we yeah we got the
space gray my first impression when I
got it first of all if you haven't seen
the Vlog of me getting my my watch when
Julian waited that was like oh yeah on
the cake that was very sweet so Julian
Julian got his was like what a month
before me like two weeks oh two weeks
before me like three weeks like three
week like 3 weeks before me and he left
his unopened in the Box in his closet
and waited for mine to come so that we
could have them together yeah I didn't
want to play with it before she had hers
it was really sweet so my first
impression was ow Julian's really sweet
but also that I loved it I I've like
I've had you know a bunch of not that I
would really call this like a sport
watch you I don't think you'd go that's
not why you would buy it you know what I
mean but I've owned like a heart rate
monitor watch before and I've also owned
like a Nike watch and I own the Nike
fuel band and this was different than
all of those and that it didn't [__]
piss me off like I I loved that it was
an appropriate size for my wrist for
like a a woman or someone with a smaller
wrist so you have the 38 and you like it
I love it I think that it's a great size
for your wrist if you have a smaller
wrist and uh it was a lot sleeker and
lighter than I thought it was going to
be and uh that also this is I love the
band I got the sport band it came with
the black band and I also bought the
green band the bright green brand both
sport both sport um I have no desire to
get the other bands I really like these
Bands A Lot awesome and uh yeah just
that I [__] loved it and the crown
was easy to use everything was
relatively easy to use more so than I
had expected for sure and that I loved
it yeah yeah I almost peeded my pants I
loved it yeah that was my first
impression um I I mean honestly I would
say my first impression is relatively
similar to yours just because the shock
factor of how nice it felt uh when I
played with it when I wore it when I
played with the crown the way you know
it switched from the watch to the
messages everything was very smooth and
I and like I had never worn a watch like
that um you had said that um you had
said that it it it was like way better
than any other sport watch you had worn
I had the same notes cuz I I was wearing
the Nike watch yeah that huge Nike huge
Nike watch and it was workout watch yeah
and I liked it but it blew that this
blew that out of the water right well
it's just like little stuff that you
don't think about that you want a
smaller watch for like doesn't stick out
like when you're putting on your shirt
or your jacket or things like that
doesn't get caught on this big bulky
watch you know what I mean um another
thing that stuck out to me right away
when I when I first put it on was I was
amazed with how well it detects when you
raise your wrist it has it it has a a
sensor for that so every time you raise
your wrist it knows that you're raising
your wrist a look at time and it's it's
very good unlike that stupid YouTube
video that was like oh it's like it's if
you don't if you have tattoos then it
doesn't sense it or like if you put it
on your your right hand it doesn't sense
it cuz I have tattoos he like no dude we
can see your wrist hitting the crown so
it's like holding it it doesn't turn
like dumb ass it's really great it's one
of the coolest things I mean I've never
had a watch just turn on when I look at
it's really cool [__] awesome um one
one of the bad things that was my first
impression was the uh cuz I first like
right away downloaded like Twitter and
Instagram for that Apple watch and I
didn't like those those apps I felt like
they were just for show the Twitter and
the Instagram they do nothing you get to
see like three tweets uh no but I'm this
is my first impression cuz when like
when I went into it like I guess that's
not really first impression but no those
are gripes talk about it was one of the
first things that I saw to be fair like
I was exploring apps and oh one one of
the other things I had written down was
the me when it popped up for
notifications blew me away the little
subtle tap it does that hatic and it's a
message and it just shows feel of it
when it Taps you is [__] amazing you
you can see videos about it but when you
what actually happens on your wrist it's
a cool thing and that was one of my cool
First Impressions um I had my actual
like the a negative first impression is
when I put it on because the battery
pack like sticks out in the back
remember I told you it like hurt my
wrist for a little bit it took me a
little bit to get used to oh yeah
because you
know a bony [__] wrist and it it does
it sticks into your wrist like more um
convex or whatever the [__] it like
sticks into your wrist a little bit Yeah
Yeah doesn't like it doesn't like mold
to your wrist no it's not flat on the
back okay all right you want to move on
to apps yeah we talking about the apps
that we like or don't like favorite apps
favorite apps ooh okay my absolute
favorite app is the Hue Lights so we've
put in a lot of the Phillips Hue like
actual light bulbs where you then
connect to Wi-Fi over like your phone
and you can use it on your watch and I
use a um app called on switch and you
can turn on and off the lights from your
watch which is the best [__] thing in
the whole world like you're upstairs
you're tired you don't want to go
downstairs so I turn off the lights with
my watch by far away my favorite [__]
app on the watch y I use that every
single day I use it all the time too
yeah um do you want to say any Dr me
just go you want to do app app app or
you want to just list yours I'll just
list minee the health features I really
like okay um because I was using
different things before so I like that I
I don't have to change my watch now do
you know what I mean although I still
have like my my jewelry going out watch
likewise I don't [__] wear that every
day no yeah it's occasion it's it was so
like I love that watch so much but I
wear it I sometimes I wear my Apple
watch and that watch I wear double
watches yeah because you know I'm like
dressed up like why the [__] never would
be a girl thats a nice watch every day
yeah no you got to [__] work out what
are you doing it's not functional oh
it's ridiculous oh did we did I skip
functionality as a category I have it
functionality is another category sorry
um ping pinging your phone really
underrated ping your phone no one's
talking about that oh it's so important
it changed my life it's no one's ever I
I didn't know about it until I tried it
I'm the I'm the person that never knows
where their phone is you just so what
she's talking about is you can go to
your watch and you swipe up and you hit
this and it it pings your phone so and
it it's good range like oh it's [__]
loud maybe like 50 m or something it's
really loud it's pretty cool man it's
amazing um touch and like the touching
each other you know what I mean how you
can and sending each other your
heartbeat I really like those because we
use the why stop cheating stop looking
at at list we we we have used it in the
past because Brett also has an Apple
Watch we've used it in the past like if
for somewhere and we we decide that we
were like at a party or like we might
want to leave we all we decided that
we're going to yeah our secret code is
we do like a white like three Taps on
each other which is like really [__]
awesome if you want a lowkey like you're
in a room with your friend that has an
Apple Watch you can tap each other you
set up code ahead of time yeah it's
[__] really it's really it is really
cool that is a cool feature we should we
should make more more codes non-verbal
we need to especially for when we're out
in the world and not just at home yeah
for sure okay is that all or you no I
have um I also really like I use it
majority like during the day when I'm
looking at it for periscope
notifications because I look watching
people on Periscope um I have that on I
will forever leave it on and I see it a
lot like during the day when people are
periscoping but it's really great you
know if you every once in a while you're
like oh my God I really want to [__]
watch that person Periscope and by the
time I see it on my phone the
notification I don't see it yeah but
with your watch never see it right away
and if I want to see someone's Periscope
I see it immediately um text
notifications same thing I really like
being able to just quickly look at the
message and then I can respond to it in
a minute do you what I mean um Uber when
your Uber is arriving and it tells you
on your watch which for me was a game
changer because I'm the same way out the
door to go out to a bar or whatever and
I'm still putting on my lipstick I'm
still you know brushing my hair or some
[__] my phone is nowhere to be found and
then my watch tells me your Uber is
arriving so I'm like [__] uh slide
puzzle and Sudoku are probably the only
two games that I like I don't have any
games and I really like that you can
answer and make phone calls from your
watch because it makes you feel like
James Bond absolutely James Bond all
right that's pretty good what are a good
list all right so I also have Uber uh I
love I love that it just tap serious
you're like oh my car's outside that's
also James Bond uh Postmates which is
similar we've recently discovered
Postmates uh it's basically a delivery
service for food um and hungry what I
discovered was you can tip you can do
the entire thing you like you order from
your phone right you're not going to
look through menus on your watch you
order from your phone once you're done
on your phone you can finish it on your
watch you you can see when they're
arriving and you can rate and tip them
from your watch which is awesome and
it's very clean it's easy to use uh
Postmates messages I am every day I'm
Blown Away by how easy it is to check a
message and respond to a message a text
message like I'm texting my brother out
of nowhere like I'm cleaning the house
I'm doing something in my hands he text
me back I glance at it two seconds later
I know exactly what he said by the time
I get to my phone I have my whole
response you know ready to go or I just
say it into the Speak Text uh which I
also have another side of the sword that
double-edged sword later on I'll talk
about it but messages absolutely love it
I use it all the time by far far the the
most used utilized function of the Apple
watch is is checking and responding to
messages on my watch mine not uh phone I
love the phone as well if if I don't
know where my physical phone is maybe
it's in my pocket or something and
someone's calling me and I'm just like
oh hello C it's crazy so phone is cool
uh clock I love the clock yeah just the
watch itself yeah I agree it's great uh
the watch face it tells you your battery
life the time the date how warm it is
out what time of sunset is whatever the
[__] you want you can put on that watch
face so I love it but I also have
problems with it which we'll talk about
uh workout app so same thing love it but
hey there's a couple really cool
features in the workout app um it tracks
you really well when you're in the
middle of a workout it gets your
calories really well your heart rate at
any moment you want to check uh distance
time elapsed you know max heart rate
average heart rate it's really really
cool there's a lot of room to improve
but it's a really and it's 10 10 steps
above where I was before right with any
any sort of sport watch so uh and then
lastly is uh pass book uh I have a
Starbucks uh app on my phone yeah and I
love paying for with my watch because
you get points or whatever but in my you
know my Apple pay you double tap the
side you go like this oh Julian loves
that double tap the side and then your
card comes up and then if you're a place
that accepts Apple pay you just touch it
with your wrist and then you're good to
go so I would say those right now are
all my favorite apps you were in a
couple of places people had never seen
people even the person at the register
the person at the register had never
seen someone pay with their watch and I
was very excited had some weird looks
when I'm like like asking for my card
and I'm just
like it'd be really funny if you just
tried to do that with like a separate
watch different no is it not
working or just like a bracelet yeah
yeah is it not are you not getting my
money or I guess I'll just leave with my
stuff that's really funny um all right
least favorite
apps well what is it the next thing that
you said was apps wish existed okay
that's right sorry ABS yeah ABS you wish
existed all right so can I go real quick
go all right so like I said the workout
functionality is great but it needs to
be better it needs to be better um for
instance there's very limiting uh you
know group of exercises that they have
preset so most of the time I click other
for a workout because it's either like
outdoor running cycling that's it you
know what I mean and I don't really do
that and so um I have to constantly find
ways to adjust that to my workout also
um there's there's like kind of zero
room built into the wash for
weightlifting it's almost all
conditioning and cardio based which is
nice and I get it that's the average
well it probably gives you an estimate
based on your average heart rate I would
just love some sort of like strength
tracking or progress tracking or any
anything like that maybe if it's just
one feature I would love it I think
there's a lot of room to improve for
that um another app I wish they had was
uh of diet tracking app I think there's
a way to do it really easily on the
watch that's very easy you know you tap
what your meals are you know Common
meals and you can just you can see your
calories right there cuz that's even
easier than checking your phone for
calories if if you're counting your
Macros and stuff I feel like that would
be a great app if it's done right
another app I wish uh they had is a
typing well it's not really an app but
it's more a mechanism to to type
messages yeah it's [__] annoying I
want you to be able to write a letter
like J M like draw the letter and then
have that I mean that something like
that there's got to be a way to not have
to just speak your response cuz if
you're in a crowded room you can't text
someone back from your watch I wish that
like even just if you were to speak your
response to someone that it would like
the way the iPhone will she be like oh
would you like me to put that into text
for you and then it puts it into text so
that the person is getting a text
message instead of your voice it does do
that no it doesn't it does do that every
time I do that it just sends that little
weird voice thing it does do that okay
here I'll do it to you right now good go
ahead wait where's you I'll talk about
some other things wait where's your
messages did we text each other today
here we go all right you ready here we
go okay go
ahead
sorry [__] you
Dale all right so it says it says [__]
you
Dale can you see that I don't know maybe
not no it looks like a Bo thing look
mhm oh [__] it deleted it damn it there
you go no it it's cuz I put my Wrist
down damn it this is bad [__] you
Dale okay now you're sending it to me
look on you could send his
audio what that says what is the that
says what is the [__] you D can you can
you like get to the you're missing the
point here you click this babe uhhuh and
it sends as a text oh it doesn't look
like it's sending
though there you
go mine has never worked mine has never
never done that You' never done the
feature properly well yeah I guess so I
thought that you could literally only
send things as a as a voice message
which really pissed me off all right
what is the what is that you were
speaking you were speaking while I was
recording my text so don't don't give
that
[__] true I'm sorry um yeah I had I just
had to quickly turn off your
notifications just for apps because if
you swipe up on your thing it gives you
the Ping it gives you the airplane mode
it gives you do not disturb and it gives
you silent I wish there was a way that
you could still get your text messages
and all that but if for some reason you
were going out and you didn't want to
get all your [__] Periscope and
Twitter notifications and all that you
could just quickly turn off your
notifications at one Tex do you know
what I mean like one swipe you'd be done
with all those okay that makes sense um
I wish that there was also I had the
same thing a more accurate Health okay
thing because the only time that I've
really like surpass my exercise goal
like well over we were driving in the
car from Vegas to Los Angeles and I was
like what the actual [__] furiously
eating cheeseburgers yeah it I was like
I'm I don't even know what the [__] is
happening um I wish uh that there was a
game where you could use the hard touch
the whole time you know how you hold it
you push down and it like clicks and it
feels amazing I'm obsessed with that
feeling and I wish there was a game
where I could only just force touch the
entire time that's why because I love it
U more fun games in general and I wish
that there was an app that would just
let you browse through gifts because
gifts turn up really funny on your watch
yeah gifts are funny on your watch I've
seen some gifts on watch it's good I
wish that there was like a a Reddit
there might be like an imager yeah but I
I yeah I don't know I just wish like a
Reddit client for just gifts or
something just for
gifts um yeah for sure that's what I was
this tell me about your gripes what
don't you like really quickly a word
from boss dogs boss dogs uh boss dogs
thank you for sponsoring the podcast
this podcast is brought to you by boss
dogs uh they are a company that create
cool awesome apparel for your dog
actually it's for you but with your dog
on it so they make shirts they make hats
cups any sort of stuff you'd want and
you send them your picture of your pet
your dog and they they do a great job of
turning it into an awesome design they
have a great graphic design team I'm
sure because they they put out some
great um live in Rochester illustrations
yeah and uh and they can put it on cups
shirts and the quality is great yes like
we have these shirts that we wear all
the time and sweatshirts uh tank tops
hats I mean even if you want a dope hat
like come on guys camo you know how I
feel about camo right um but there's
also nothing more awesome than like
walking your dog or being with your dog
while your dog is on your shirt but not
just like a oh hey I went on [__]
Teespring or no not te that's where I
what is the uh Cafe Press where you're
like oh I copied and pasted this from my
desktop and now it's like a square image
of your dog no it looks cool it looks
like it should be a designer piece of
clothing that's that's the cool part it
looks very awesome it looks very cool
all you do is it's your dog it's your
dog do they do it for other animals or
just dogs I think it's just dogs just
dogs you'd have to check out with boss
dogs so you check out a boss do I'm sure
you could be like would you do this for
a mini giraffe and they'd be like looks
like Kermit yeah we can do that just if
you call it a dog you're like hey this
is my dog and you send a picture of a
giraffe bossg co.com use Jenna Julian at
checkout for 10% off they are awesome
check them out uh my
gripes okay there's no custom watch face
there's like five options for a watch
face annoyed about why are there five
options and one of them is Mickey Mouse
who made that call at Apple who was like
hey uh I have an idea the coolest thing
about this watch is how you're going to
look at it and it's going to be a
[__] digital watch on your on your
wrist and you can't do a damn thing to
customize it also we're going to give
them five choices one of them is Mickey
tapping his foot cuz everyone loves that
on their
watch oh Julian's going to lose it right
now I mean if there was a way to
jailbreak my watch I probably would just
because of that that one thing I hate
like this is the one I use which is just
the digits 21 24 that's all it says I
wish I could have that in big in big
numbers but also have a small date also
have a small battery life right there
like this is well that's why I use the
one that's kind of mixed it has like
that's what I used
battery and the I like having all that
cuz I don't need to see anything I do
too but I like the numbers big so when I
had the Nike watch they were big numbers
and I loved it right so that's my number
one gripe that you should be able to
make a custom watch or maybe developers
can make custom watch faces you can
download them or something just not make
only Apple watch faces that's right yeah
you have the cycles of the Moon you have
some space g Mickey Mouse his I deleted
it you can delete watch faces I deleted
yeah I deleted it I can't even find them
that mad yeah I hated it uh my other
gripe is ever since I've started wearing
the Apple watch I charged my phone twice
a day yeah and that is consistent never
a day where I don't have to charge my
phone before I go to sleep true it sucks
but that's the way it is the phone is
constantly feeding the watch information
via Bluetooth and it just it drains the
battery of the phone and the watch will
last a day and a half that's fine but
the phone dies three4 of the way through
every day for me so I feel like my
watching my phone by the end of the day
because I I'm bad at charging things
they're both just like super F that's
why though are you hot honey you're
pretty horrible at charging yeah it's
hot in here um I think he's hot why
don't you go on the ground but be a good
boy and be quiet okay boss dog my ball
boss dogs um it's hot right you hot yes
[__] um so it kills your iPhone battery
and your watch battery my watch battery
lasts a day and a half sometimes two
days mine doesn't cuz sometimes I like
to do like little games and stuff on I
never play a single game on my watch
well that like the first day that I had
the watch it was like died like two
hours everything was dead everything was
dead cuz you're was sitting there
playing with it but like over the course
of you know time you know you figure out
how often you need to recharge it based
on what you use it for yeah um the band
I you know the sport band's cool but I
honestly feel like the Apple band
selection is a little weak uh I've been
I've been wearing third party bands
with an adap thing because I just I want
to we I want to mix it up and I feel
like you either have to spend $150 on a
leather band or a sport band or you just
kind of like they're like [__] you you
know so I can't wait till more third
party bands come out I can't wait till
better adapter systems come out for
different bands um I also just I'm not a
huge fan of the home
screen the cluster I'm yeah I can't say
that I'm the biggest fan of that either
because in theory you know how well are
you going to organize a [__] ton of apps
other than in a way where you can kind
of get to all of them it's kind of a
[__] mess it's a mess somebody needs
to think I mean it works but you know
when you're thinking about when you need
to get on your watch and check something
really quick like say your phone is
tucked away in your backpack and you
need to check this one text message and
you're like [__] I'm in this giant
cluster of apps where's my you know what
I mean so it's not very [__] cluster
of yeah there's yeah so the I think
they'll change that honestly about the
bands for me I'm completely happy with
my sport band like I I don't really want
any of the Apple bands it was never like
a Temptation for me to start looking for
other bands but if there was some really
cool bands that existed like I would I
wouldn't want something that looked more
like a watch I would want something like
more playful exciting yeah you know what
I mean like the green I have a bright
green one which I like but if there was
stuff that I don't even [__] know
existed like you got some of that water
in there with glitter and [__]
butterflies I would buy that that you
know what I mean I hear you you like to
keep the theme of like Goofy and like
fun if you made crazy [__] I would buy
it but I don't want your like shitty
chain [__] leather I don't want any
I'm not a huge fan of any of their
designs either I mean the leather
because if I want to wear that I will
wear my actual watch do you know what I
mean yeah no I like the the reason I
wear this one the nylon one is cuz it's
like it's you can wear it for sport but
it also looks like uh like sort of a
nice watch like sort of military where
did you find that I got this band on
Amazon for 10s and I got these these
adapters on Amazon for same like 20
bucks and I used these adapters for
multiple watch bands that I bought yeah
I said the other thing I said about the
band that I don't like aside from the
fact that I do like it but the green one
the light colored ones if you're a girl
and you wear fake tan it gets all
[__] over it or the white one it
pisses me off you seen the inside of my
it's funny I love when your your wrist
yeah Julian like makes fun of me
relentlessly cuz I have a circle of like
no fake tan and the bom like your fake
tan is super ratchet when you wear the
Apple watch because it just like takes
it off that makes me bad yeah uh I can't
relate to that but I'm sorry maybe maybe
they should have but like of all the
jewelry that I wear really my Apple
watch is the thing that like well yeah
cuz you it it you know it's going to
sound gross but it kind of like keeps
the sweat in there like this SP material
I know I'm sorry [__] ratchet ass
watch at least your face still looks I
said the battery wasn't great drained
your phone I said Twitter is unused
Instagram is I mean Twitter really who's
going to want to load the top four
tweets on a timeline four tweets I
follow what you can't see mentions you
can't see your own profile yeah I can't
go to my home you know feed that I can't
do that oh my God you can't even go to
your at mentions there's no mentions
there's no there's no explore there's no
hashtags it's just you get to see four
or five tweets that are on your and even
they were on the right track in theory
when they were like all right how what
can we show you on the the watch we'll
show you trending topics but then when
you go to the trending topics you can't
see like you know pictures or other
people's tweets there's no links to an
absolute joke they they put Twitter on
the watch so they could say there's
Twitter on the watch absolutely unusable
I think I've opened it twice since I've
had the watch same with Instagram just
to show someone else how unusable pretty
frustrating it's terrible yep um those
are my gripes all right so functionality
now is that what we have next I mean I
just said that it was oh works yeah I
think we kind of cover the charger I
think we kind of covered the
functionality and that I'm obsessed with
the hard touch I want there to be a game
where I can do nothing but you know
they're bringing Force touch to the next
iPhone right well I I'm going to need
that because I just want to hard touch
things you're really cute it feels so
good I love that it's a good it's a cool
like sensation it it feels like you're
like pushing through it it does you push
and then it get it break you know the
feeling that you get when you you have
like your little handheld hole puncher
and you're punching holes and things as
a kid m or like you have the plastic
ones that like pop it feels like you're
punching hole in a piece of paper but
with your finger you're going yeah oh I
hear what you're saying it's like the
most satisfying your finger through yeah
yeah I love it cuz it doesn't give it
first and then it gives yeah okay cool
it's the best well we should get the
iPhone 6s then 6s no sheep that the 6s
is having Force touch babe a no I'll
wait till the till the next one how
might I just get the 6s e if it comes
with better battery life I'm buying it
I'm no choice I'm I'm I'm going I'm
going to have to take a mortgage on
everything because of the amount of
charges I buy mortgage I'm just kidding
but like the I was like what
mortgage the amount of chargers we've
bought for our phones yeah and I don't
know somehow they're not here yeah they
do they have a tendency to disappear
anytime they're going to say one of the
biggest reasons I bought the 6 Plus cuz
better battery life I can't I can't
handle the charging phone it's like I
feel like I'm on a
landline I don't I I don't know how your
phone dies so fast maybe it's because I
don't use my phone as much as you do
well you're on your phone is either dead
or on the charger all day every day well
I mean I feel like I use it a lot and
it's just that low battery but it it
doesn't maybe I'm not aware of how low
it is all the time because you just live
on the edge so when it's like under 10%
like you don't care yeah care I just
wait till it's dead and then I'm like oh
it's
dead um I'm I'm I'm not 100% I mean
we're not talking about the iPhone I
don't know I'm going to get it or not
but yeah the I hate that you know oh did
did I say in
gripes have we gone over all the gripes
yet cuz I missed one no keep going okay
the next generation of the watch needs
to be completely independent of the
iPhone yeah it's kind of annoying it's
pretty frustrating cuz it's a useless
thing when you don't have your phone and
that's not right like if someone wants
to just buy an Apple Watch and they want
to use their Galaxy on the other hand
like let them do that stop making it
attached to the watch or to the phone
right it's frustrating cuz it could be a
cool it could be a cool accessory for
anyone but it's not because it has to
have an iPhone with it I agree I agree
be independent it is really annoying
though too it like cuz I've gone on
walks and stuff you walk the dogs I
don't bring my phone with me and then
all of a sudden it gives you that little
red flashy thing that you don't have
your phone and I'm like what the [__]
man what the actual [__] yeah can't use
anything I know it's really frustrating
it needs to it needs to like I don't
know something needs to be fixed
agreed um yeah I had those [__]
unusable I I think I think for the Next
Generation for software I had for you
know whatever I want there to be a
camera on the watch really yes I want it
to have like even if it has a shitty
lens or it's like super [__] fishee
or whatever I really want there to be a
[__] camera on the watch cuz I think
it would be really fun if you could
FaceTime from your watch or if you could
take pictures from your watch even just
for Snapchat and I also said that you
need to be able to actually use social
media on the watch or else this is just
going to [__] it's going to fade away
well people you people can't justify
buying another watch without being able
to useal Media what what do you what
would what would happen if they they're
like okay we'll build the dope ass
camera on this we'll make FaceTime a
function doesn't need to be dope I just
want it to be fun we'll make a dope ass
camera FaceTime is now a function
Snapchat is now a function on your watch
yeah you FaceTime for 10 minutes you
Snapchat three times your phone your
your watch is at 50% period there's no
way around
that I mean unless they come up with
some insane small compact battery that
is going to blow everyone away which
they might CU they're Apple but it seems
like you know the more the the
more physical [__] that they put on the
watch the more is just going to kill the
battery which is already a problem you
know what I feel like should be an
option is that they sell those M packs
for your watch I know that they do I
know that they do but Apple needs to
work way around being able to gain
battery power while it's on you do you
know what I mean whether that means that
you you you're able to I don't know do
something plug it in somehow or charge
it somehow while you're still using it
the way that you can a phone because to
me that sucks if I'm just around the
house or around a charger I can't charge
my watch without taking it off and
leaving it do you know what I mean I I
wish there was a way for you to charge
it while you're using it like you would
your phone I think I think well I think
the biggest reason I know they've
thought of that I think the biggest
reason is it gets hot and that's like a
safety concern yeah the watch get I mean
anything gets hot when you charge it but
have you felt your watch like while it's
charging cuz it gets pretty warm and if
it's on your wrist while it's charging
it could be like sort of a safety maybe
they should just write a thing on there
it says don't charge on your wrist if
you're a sensitive dumbass there we go
Apple take notes because that is what
you need to do you have her business if
you do that say don't put it on the
don't put on your wrist if you're going
to complain to us about being hot it's
hot all right you either put it on your
wrist and be hot or don't [__] off
that's legal
jargon uh yeah no that's that's proper
we can get a lawyer to say that why
would we need a lawyer though but like
really though it it makes me upset cuz I
like it I like the watch I get upset
when I have to take it off to charge it
cuz then you don't have it you know but
if you're using your phone and you want
to sit down and charge it while you use
it you can
it pisses me off that brings me to
another Point completely unrelated but
these new phones that sit on a pod to
charge how do you use them while they're
charging do you just have to like I
don't know what is that did nobody think
of that I don't know I don't know you
guys know what I'm talking about right
those little [__] circles that you
put your phone on now that charge
they're like oh it's the future how do
you use it while it's charging do you
have to just like tap on it like a like
you're like you don't know how to type
on a keyboard yeah for people that go to
work and you plug your phone you get to
your job at your desk like how are you
going to use I haven't researched it so
I might be sounding like an ass right
now but please tell me there's like a
cord that you can also I mean really
like yeah maybe charge it really old
school yeah so overall overall would you
recommend someone buy the Apple watch I
think that if you're a fan of apple and
that you have other Apple products and
that you've always wanted a piece of
wearable technology that you would enjoy
the Apple watch I think that if you are
someone that's looking for you know
something that you're going to use a lot
for all of its features I don't use all
the features I I would say wait you know
or get uh some people like the Samsung
ones and stuff there's a lot of cool
smart watches a lot of people like yeah
I wouldn't recommend this for someone
that was looking for the best smartwatch
or whatever or wearable technology this
is not for you fair enough I think that
this is for hardcore fans of Apple that
you know are the same as I am or you are
that like you know if Apple came out
with a [__] microphone I would buy it
if they came out with a [__] chair I
would buy it you know what I mean sheep
I'm a sheeple and I'm proud of it and I
give no [__] yeah we're sheep for Apple
for sure but I also it works seamlessly
with all of my other Technologies I mean
it's hard to beat that it's I can't I
don't want to be going back and forth
yeah absolutely it pisses me off I said
something similar um if you're a person
who wants the latest Tech wearable tech
uh and you don't want to leave Apple yes
get the Apple watch because it's going
to give you that experience it's going
to give you a wearable it's going to
give you a smartwatch which is a cool
[__] thing that I've never had I
really like I like I like having a
smartwatch um it's a fun device it has
many uses some of which I'm still Blown
Away by every day I'm like I said I'm
still kind of in awe that this exists
and it's on my wrist um you know there
are obviously things that need work so
if you're expecting a perfect product
don't don't expect a perfect product
definitely frustrating things about it
and it's not perfect but you know I
think in in a sense everyone who lined
up and bought this since this came out
understood that it's not a perfect thing
they're like this is the Apple watch
this is Apple's version of a market
that's been huge for like two years
three years and now they're coming out
we have to see what it is right and
that's why we got it so if you're if
you're into that and if you think you
know that that experience is worth it
which we deemed worth it then get an
Apple Watch right and I I also think
it's important to note that I would not
recommend getting anything above the
sport I think unless you're in love with
the shiny stainless steel no it's not
worth it I mean it's 100 bucks more I
honestly don't even think that they
needed to exist I think that that was
just a way for them to make money back
[__] Rich ass people here's the thing
a lot of people tell me that the
addition needed to exist no I'm not I
disagree with that I'm not talking about
the addition I'm talking about the Apple
watch we have the Apple watch sport I
think honestly the there's probably a
giant group of people similar to the
amount of people who wanted a sporty
watch that wanted a watch that they
could wear their business meetings yeah
so they wanted the shiny the crown you
know they wanted it to be shiny and then
get a leather band so they're like oh
this is my new watch if they come in
with like a sport band even if they can
switch out a leather band on the sport
watch it's somehow not the same
that's Apple's job of marketing that's
100100 to $200 more for the regular and
they're selling them so no I know they
are I just think like if you're just
going to you know [__] it man let's make
a watch let's make a cluster [__] of
apps in the beginning Mickey Mouse on
the front [__] it just throw out the
sport first then for the second
generation make them watches you know
what I mean but make them what they are
now which is like a functional cute nice
watch don't try and pass it off in the
watch market and don't even try and pass
it off in the wearable technology Market
or the luyet you're not holding a candle
to any of them just do one thing do it
okay and make the people that love Apple
happy yeah well you forget that they
like to make us happy but they also like
to make them happy so and they also like
to make money which is the only reason
why you would ever make a gold [__]
watch like this I just can't like I
imagine as a collector's item it pissed
you'd be if you had a gold watch right
now like you spent 17 or however much
[__] thousand and you're like wow
this [__] thing has a lot of problems
with it and I got a gold one oh it's
dead
again oh my phone died because of my
$112,000
item oh those people don't give a [__]
though oh no they don't they don't but
yeah I think that if you're a fan of
apple and you know cuz I've talked to
Justine about it and she sort of has the
same feelings that it's a really
exciting watch but it's it's a watch you
know it's it does a little bit more than
your average watch but it's still watch
and there's still room from Improvement
but you know I'm I've been happy with it
I I wear it every single day we love the
watches we wear it all the time yeah and
I think if you have $300 or whatever
that you are a fan of Apple products you
would love it yeah it's very [__]
awesome especially if you have friends
that have it and then you can tap each
other yeah there's nothing like that
it's really fun you can draw dicks and
stuff if you guys have any questions
that we didn't cover hit us in the
comments about what you want to know
because we'll we'll answer about the Ala
watch we want to give you guys the best
sort of review of it that we can because
then the only thing I can think of that
we didn't cover at all is the fact that
it is water resistant I've never taken a
shower with it but supposedly you can it
feels wrong I was in the Apple Store to
take a shower with it I was in the Apple
Store and some Genius Bar employee was
was asked if it's water resistant and
she
said apparent she was like we tell you
guys that you can take a shower with it
but I wouldn't do that I was like [__]
thank you you yeah uh I don't know why
you ever take a shower with it's for
when you get pushed in a pool like come
on going to oh I'm all naked but this
watch can handle it so I'm going to just
jump
in just treat it like any other piece of
technology but also I'd like to note
that in terms of it being a watch
because I've had you know lots of
plastic watches and shitty watches in my
life this has not dented or scratched or
not even the screen not there's no
damage whatsoever and I've hit it on
[__] I yeah I knock it around all the
time it has held up shockingly well I
didn't think it was going to it's an I
thought it was going to look like the
back of the [__] iPod touch or iPod
the first generation IP yeah the back of
everyone's iPod was just all
scratched so terrible that's what I
thought that the outside of the watch
and even the screen would potentially
look like and it doesn't at all yep well
anyway um I I I enjoyed talking about it
yeah kind of reminded me that we got
cool devices it's pretty [__] cool um
this podcast is brought to you by boss
dogs check out boss doco.com to get your
own dog put on really cool merchandise
hell and you can buy shirts hats cups
whatever you want or if you just want a
cool camo boss dogs hat go check them
out boss doco.com enter Jenna Julina
checkout for 10% off thank you BOS dos
for your support and thank you guys for
watching the podcast this week uh we'll
see you again next week we got a crazy
week coming up uh but we'll see you
again next week for another podcast we
talk about all the stuff dink
dink love you guys love you I like your
hat
thanks oh does your shirt say one of
these things is not like the otter yeah
somebody sent this my shirt is a picture
of five otter and one of them's a
penguin it says one of these things is
not like the not like the Otter Otter
that's all you
are
[Music]